Why should computers learn to see?
Because old friends can now connect
in real-time.
Because no one should have to go hungry.
Because we believe in second chances.
From agriculture to cancer detection,
computer vision is not only teaching
computers what to see but how
to respond to our visual world.
At Udacity, we've built the computer vision
Nanodegree program for students to
learn about image processing techniques
and methods for object recognition
and tracking
So that you can make a deep
impact in any field.
So why should we teach computers to see?
Cause the possibilities of what we can build together are limitless.